es ist ein wirklich ein rätselhafter
meeresgiganten vor der australischen
westküste haben fachleute das wohl
größte exemplar der sogenannten starts
quallen aufgespürt das jemals
dokumentiert wurde doch diese tiefsee
kreatur erstaunt nicht nur aufgrund
ihrer gigantischen größe auch ihre
zusammensetzung also ihr körperbau ist
extrem spooky klicks um science-fiction
ihr gezeigt die spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktivität locke
nur dann verpasst er nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen die staatsgalerie
ein australisches forschungsteam jetzt
im indischen ozean aufgespürt hat ist
wirklich riesig die hat einen
durchmesser von 15 metern und gilt somit
als das größte exemplar dieser art das
jemals dokumentiert wurde die bislang
aufgespürten tiere seien gerade einmal
so 20 zentimeter bis einen meter lang
gewesen die bizarre tiefsee kreatur
kommt auf eine volle länge von achtung
120 metern das ist in etwa so groß wie
das upper west gebäude in berlin und der
city tower in offenbach am main hoch
sind die filmaufnahmen gelangen mit
hilfe eines ferngesteuerten
unterwasserfahrzeugen vor der
australischen westküste in einer tiefe
von 630 metern sie zeigen wie sich die
staats qualle in einer riesigen spirale
ausbreitet alleine außenring wird auf
eine länge von 47 metern geschätzt die
meeresbiologin und geologen gehen davon
aus dass diese bizarre tiefsee kreatur
schon einige jahrzehnte oder sogar
jahrhunderte als sein könnte an sich
sind die sogenannten starts qualen in
der fachsprache auch als iphone nur
fauré bekannt schon seit längerer zeit
bekannt doch das nun gefilmte exemplar
bezeichnet die wissenschafts community
tatsächlich als besonders denn als die
forschenden genauer hinsah machten sie
eine überraschende entdeckung das wesen
besteht nicht nur aus einem einzelnen
organismus sondern aus unzähligen
spezialisierten klonen seiner selbst
dazu die us meeresbiologin rebecca hin
dass gebildet bestehend aus millionen
miteinander verbundenen klonen ganz so
als hätten die burg aus star trek kinder
mit den kriegern aus star wars dabei
übernimmt jeder einzelne clown
unterschiedliche aufgaben jeder einzelne
clown ist auf eine bestimmte aufgabe
spezialisiert die fachleute ziehen den
vergleich zu einem bienenvolk bei der
stadt cali allerdings seien die bienen
aneinander befestigt und in einem großen
organismus
realisiert sogar die forschenden selbst
sind von ihrer entdeckung fasziniert
dazu die biologin rebecca hennig habe
zahlreiche expeditionen unternommen und
noch nie so etwas gesehen dieses tier
ist massiv und nicht nur massiv es zeigt
ein atemberaubendes verhalten es ist auf
der jagd demnach verfügen manche der
klone über haken die auf spezialisiert
sind beute zu machen
sobald einer der kleinen fisch oder ein
krebs tier eingefangen hat leitet er es
quasi weiter andere klone die als münder
fungieren umgeben ihn sobald die beute
verdaut ist werden die nährstoffe durch
einen extrem langen verdauungstrakt
geschickt der sich durch die gesamte
kolonie zieht so kann jeder einzelne
clown die nährstoffe nutzen dazu
schreibt die wissenschaftlerin rebecca
handys ist eines der größten und
beeindruckendsten supernovae den ich je
gesehen habe wahrscheinlich gibt es
millionen oder milliarden von ihnen wer
weiß welche anderen kreaturen wir sehen
werden wenn wir den ozean meer erkunden
rätselhaftes objekt auf dem meeresgrund
der ostsee
mysteriös ufo anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren
bis danach ja krieg zum science fiction
bis dann bleibt dran